from world-class footballer to star
manager now he's being called a tax
fraud Olli harness deposited millions in
a Swiss bank account to avoid paying tax
in Germany his case is becoming an
election topic but what did Germans
think should there be a tougher crack
down on tax evaders there's looking onto
Klein a so-called little man gets taxed
until he's got barely anything in his
pocket but others get away with it or
just get a slap on the wrist that's
covered EST leaked demas them so we need
measures for sure because money that's
earned in Germany or a wealth that's
been acquired here should also be taxed
appropriately in Germany estoy you'd
been up to now it's always been the low
wage workers who pay up whereas hire a
nurse don't at all but they are the ones
with the money twenty four percent of
Germans think enoughs being done to
tackle tax evasion but more than
two-thirds say more must be done to curb
fraud evidently tax owaisi still exist
and they need to be closed although
that's difficult for Germany to do on a
worldwide level food or charge here use
this vid bites a button you will see
everyone has to take responsibility
you've got to start with yourself rather
than making politicians or the state
responsible I've got to start with
myself it was bug me on phone but the
majority of Germans do support the
government purchasing CDs with data of
people shoring money abroad
you